[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale 50 raso journal
foulée l'ol j'espère qu'elles seront
sociaux tel brian grant portable
n'affaiblit pas ce coup-ci des petites
comme ayral eu de très gros total le
petit écho de la forêt c'est la trêve re
s'est déroulé il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le cul des cours de nos
forums
[Rires]
voyons voyons voyant quelles sont les
nouvelles aujourd'hui cher téléphone ou
mademoiselle de la cigogne envoie un
message est spécial on n'arrête pas le
progrès c'est la compagnie mais qui êtes
vous je me présente je m'appelle pipeau
pour vous servir
c'est un pigeon infirmatif je suis un
pigeon mais un pigeon voyageur l'once
alors vous voyagez beaucoup
affirmatif j'ai fait le tour du monde
plusieurs fois plein fouet fouette
pipeau comme vous me voyez j'arrive tout
droit de venise derny formatif g2
famille là bas et il est vide et villes
y font nous rendre les visites négatif
je suis en mission spéciale lundi
spécial c'est du pareil au même
donc je suis venu en mission spéciale
oui c'est un espion négatif j'ai un
message à remettre au nom du peuple à
club vous la connaissez c'est nous alors
tenez il le messager spéciale tandis
qu'une carte postale venant de venise
venise à avoir beaucoup pigeon ma
famille ici pas de montrer votre famille
que vous êtes venu de gros tubes pop
kingdom c'est une touriste qui m'a
demandé de vous la portez une touriste
affirmatif
vous savez une grande chose un grand
show haute sur pattes au dessus avec un
long bec qui l'on est et qui fait tout
plein de manières mazel un soudain tout
juste augus et qu'est ce qu'elle dure
sur lequel vous avez qu à lui aussi
d'épées payet b melloul est moi aussi
autrement dit les membres de pia pia
club ne savez pas lire mais ne voulait
pas l'avouer à pipo le pigeon tu es prêt
chez vous savez pas
mais s'il est que vous n'avez pas vos
lunettes
moi moi moi moi avait-il aussi vous
sauver lui rue on dit viser c'est du
pareil au même
l'urée mon pote et baisse est due aux
cartes postales rocher je viens de
mademoiselle de la fifa 11 voilà ce
qu'elle nous dit lui vu ce qu'elle écrit
ballon on dirait des pâtres deux
cigognes
alors il va mieux je vais bien et je
vois bien à bientôt signer mission
accomplie nos amis ne voulant pas être
en reste voulurent que pippo le pigeon
ramène un message pour mademoiselle de
la cigogne
il faut une carte postale ne trompent
pas quand on va faire une photo de vous
tirer le portrait à tous et ça fera une
carte postale tout le monde leur place
la photo prise par pipo le pigeon fut
très réussie mais il y avait encore un
problème à gaz on lui dit il faut
quelque chose de gentil des pionniers
d'un futur louis affectueuse et surtour
originale elle est trouvée voilà ce
qu'on va être nous allons bientôt signer
nous vous avez vous su la compagnie faux
partait déjà furent battus nous pas
manger petits morceaux avec nous
négatifs jeux consoles gauche plus pour
à bientôt sur battu dans ce prof pipeau
le pigeon parti à tire d'aile il volait
si vite que ce que pour ça qu'il voulait
battre un record du monde
c'est parti
bientôt pour une prochaine édition du
petit écho de la treille tout